[Music]
that's me I wrote a blog starter block
back in 2014 and I didn't really know I
was thinking about other than I wanted
to write about front-end development
today I helped over 40,000 developers a
month with their front-end related
questions I never thought that my
smaller block would be able to help so
many people so writing this blog and
helping people is an honor for me I also
didn't think that I would be able to
write books or courses but I did so
anyway
in 2015 I launched my first book that's
called learning Suzie in 2016 I launched
my second book automating a workflow in
2017 my first course mastering
responsive typography and just two weeks
ago I launched the latest one learn
JavaScript in 2018 I never would have
gotten so far without writing writing
has taught me a lot about communication
about talking to people about creating
relationships and even about selling the
things that I make and today I'd like to
share with you three things that I've
learned through the process of writing I
believe that these three things are
important for all of us so three lessons
here's the first one silence the inner
critic we all have a critic at the back
of our hitch
it's the voice that tells us not to
write the blog post that we wanted to
write it's the voice that tells us not
to contribute to open source because we
are not good enough it is the voice that
tells you not to ask your boss for a
raise because you're going to get fired
instead of getting the race that you
want and that's the voice that tells me
not to stand on stage today to share
with you about writing
because I'm gonna embarrass myself in
front of 400 people this voice goes by
many names Steven Pressfield calls it
the resistance Seth Godin calls it the
lizard brain some of us will know it as
the imposter syndrome I'm just gonna
call it the critic today the thing about
the critic is whenever you want to do
something important it will be there to
stop you it will say nasty things in
your face it will try to make you lose
confidence and you will probably lose
confidence along the way it will and the
sucky part about this all is that the
more important something is to you the
more you care about the results that you
want to make the louder the critic gets
many people think that the critic will
go away when you become more experienced
unfortunately it doesn't the critic gets
louder as you become more experienced
because you're playing at bigger stakes
sir Sweden who is a front-end developer
there respect a lot still here security
and I'm sure that the speakers that have
gone before me have experienced the
critic and the speaker's they will go
after me will also experience the critic
as well so to overcome the critic your
honor consider a question what is more
important is what you are doing more
important or is the critic more
important if what you are doing is more
important than the critic are you
willing to pull it above the critic if
you are then start doing the work start
talking to people start designing start
making the thing that you want to make
no matter whether it's for profit or for
fun it doesn't matter just start doing
it do it over and over and over again
and you'll learn to tell the critic that
hey it's okay leave it to me
trust me to handle things and if it all
goes to
[ __ ] the world probably wouldn't end I
will probably be able to handle things
and it's fine we leave the CNR they so
do the work do it because it's important
to you and do it because it's important
to all of us second lesson it's about
them there are many ways to take in this
lesson so here's a few here's the first
way the work that you put into whatever
you want to do it's about them not you
not anyone else if you want a raise from
your boss then you kind of have to think
about your boss it's not about you
anymore if you want better relationship
with your family members it's about your
family members not about you if you want
to write a blog post and you want it to
be good you think about the readers who
are reading your blog posts not about
you not about anyone else if you put the
focus on the work on them you release
the focus on yourself and when you
release the focus on yourself there your
critic weakens yes
the kriti will still tell you that you
are lousy and what she teach what she
teaches you got yourself into like what
am i doing over here
and it will tell you how unfair the
world is but it doesn't matter anymore
because what's important is about them
it's about the people you're trying to
help it's about the people who will read
your work not anyone else so let's say
you put a critic aside and you manage to
put on some work what's the most scary
thing that's going to happen for all of
us
the most scary thing that's going to
happen is that people will ignore you
and that is going to happen nobody will
see your work nobody will notice your
existence and that is going to happen
and here's the second way to think about
this lesson because people are busy
their lives people don't care about you
they don't care about your work they
don't care about what you do all they
care about is themselves and the things
they want to care about so just think
about it this way
you don't care about a person who is
sitting two seats away in front of you
in this conference don't you not unless
you know them personally so don't worry
about what others think of your work and
don't worry if others don't pay
attention to what you are trying to say
because if you focus on helping them if
you focus on them sooner or later they
will notice you and when they do notice
you some of them will thank you for the
work that you do some of them will
encourage you to write more to do more
and some of them will [ __ ] on you and
that comes to the third lesson you
further face haters gonna hate if they
hate your work that is fine because it's
not about you it's about them what they
are doing is underneath the who if you
think about it think about a person you
hate or you dislike why do you dislike
this person or why do you hate this
person if you dive deep into the
question you're going to come with an
answer that feels somewhat similar to
this
I hate or dislike this person because of
a personal experience that I hate about
this situation so that is what haters is
actually doing they are not hating your
work they are not hating you they are
hating and experience that they have
about someone else or about themselves
so don't let your protec smash you for
something that is not your fault
don't let your critic smash you for a
problem that belongs to someone else go
in there put in the work because it is
important for all of us now is one I
have to say that sometimes reasonable
people say hateful things to enjoy
fifteen I wrote my first guest post for
Smashing Magazine and you guys probably
know what Smashing Magus if not you
wouldn't be here so I will it shouldn't
explain in 2015 I wrote my first post I
put it everything I got to make it the
best post I have ever written so far the
more the morning the guest post got
released I checked my Twitter feed and I
saw this I felt confused and bizarre
that this article was published in the
prestigious website like Smashing
Magazine and mind you this is a from a
hater this was from expert that I
respected it hurts it took me a while to
get over it emotionally and you can see
that it's still hurting me right now but
bear in mind that whatever the expert
said about you is his or her opinion as
well whatever the experts say doesn't
mean that your work is [ __ ] it doesn't
mean that your work is not valid because
if you focus on the people you are
trying to help and the people get it
then it's all worth it I know the
article was good because people came
back and thank me for it so remember
it's all about them not about you not
about the experts not anyone else and
with that let me come to my third lesson
and that is be human as humans we have a
gift we have the ability to put
ourselves in someone else's shoes we can
empathize with people but we don't use
it many of us don't I'm pretty sure the
expert who wrote the tweet didn't care
about my feelings as someone was trying
to contribute back to the community I'm
pretty sure he didn't he or she didn't I
can't forget he or she
but why why don't we empathize different
people more one reason maybe because we
are so absorbed in our own worlds that
we completely forgot that anyone else
exists and we don't care about them at
all and as I said another reason might
be because we are brought up that way we
are brought up to treat people how you
want others to treat you and to us that
is respect but there's a fatal flaw in
this statement because it assumes that
you and I are the same it assumes that
you and I like the same things
yep but I am NOT you and you are not me
we like and dislike different things I
don't want to be treated like you I want
to be treated like me and that applies
to all of us in this room and everyone
else in the world so instead of treating
people how you want them to treat you I
say you treat them how they need you to
treat them need not want because
sometimes you need to treat people
harshly for their own sake for example
if your kids are naughty sometimes you
have to spoil them you one like that
they won't like that but you need to do
it for their sake but how do you treat
people how do how do you know how to
treat people and how better duner need
them or not and for that you need to put
yourself in their shoes you need to
figure out what they are feeling before
you can find out but empathy is
difficult it is tempting to say come
into the room and say that I know oh
it's an it's tempting to come into the
room
say that I know exactly what you are
feeling so that's why you should do this
and follow my instructions that is
[ __ ] my friend that is [ __ ]
because there is no way that you won't
know how I feeling because you are not
me and you have not gone through my
experiences so you don't know that
magnitude of my fears of my anxieties of
my worries and of my pain there is no
way but if you are willing to you can
come close and if you are being real
about it
you can make a connection in that moment
and when you make a connection in that
moment that is when we open up people
open up we open up because we know you
understand us and we know you care and
we trust you we trust your words this is
the golden moment where everything
methods because what you say even though
if you don't know it what you say will
stay in their hearts for a long long
time to come and if they don't act on
what you say if they don't act on your
advice that is fine because what snakes
is up to them you have done your work
what snakes is about them and with that
I would like to wrap up the top for
today I believe that these three lessons
silence a critique is about them not you
and being human are three lessons that
are very important for all of us over
here why let's imagine for a moment if
all of us in this room and I mean just
all of us in this room only not anyone
else who is outside watching the stream
not anyone else who is at home reading
watching the live stream if all of us in
this room follow these three lessons if
we all put aside our critics if we all
focus on the people we want to help if
we encourage and help each other and
understand each other and the people we
want to help what can we build in 10
years what kind of war will really
in ten years now imagine if everyone in
the world does the same thank you
[Applause]